in this week's cover Johan Norberg says
that we're living in the Golden Age so
we went to find out if people are Greek
do you think that now is the best of a
time to be alive oh no I would really
consideration though no I choose we've
become to rattle can consumers alike
moment and this guillotine to digital
age click on to digital and like you
sleepy both instead of engaging with one
other and restaurants to go ahead from
smartphone multiplying certainly in this
part of the world probably yeah even if
he is struggling hmmm well there's
certainly arguments for it and but I
think this is also quite a strong
argument that the previous generation
perhaps had as good a time of it or if
not a bit of time of it than we did I
think we're too exposed to both the bad
things in the worst things in the world
just feel like social media so depends
you know as you said if you can afford
to live in London way I live in South
Kensington or Chelsea great course great
place to live but I mean I'm an act i go
where work is so who knows I think wall
so we also have to defy ourselves and
see we're also very privileged people
compared to a lot of people in the world
just because I like where we were born
and I found these not background so
you'll have to take that into account
those perhaps more pork and for younger
generations and and see the generation
that came before mainland there is no I
to KGB the IRA I probably would have
looked at listen and I look attractive
choice applause in iget I would think I
would probably say the nineteen
seventies then for partly because I was
young when we'd like to read more pick
up a copy of this week spectator